so it's that time of the day again it's
time to do some part work and other
things that I really needed to do on
this OC thingamajig and this is gonna be
one of those annoying boring episodes
that I don't even want to do honestly
YouTube is all about fun and I
definitely really enjoy doing all of
this but they're just something that you
need to get over in order to get to the
fun stuff and actually finish a
rollercoaster which was it's loads of
fun as well just looking back at it and
of like that it's basically all already
worth actually trying to make something
but mmm I feel like I really need to
finish up on the fences that I have but
first of all I saw this and my OCD
doesn't quite like this so I'm going to
fix this also I usually talk all the
friggin time and non-stop basically but
I am going to kind of cut that down in
this episode simply because multiple
reasons but one of them is being the
fact that I don't really have anything
to talk about at some point and I'm not
sure whether I really want to just
randomly talk about other random things
and then there's the fact that I've
burnt my tongue and I don't feel really
comfortable talking and moving it around
and been stopped like that so yeah
that's basically that and speaking of
fences don't really know exactly what to
use I think I'm just gonna go with
branches again yeah I guess I think
there's anything better in here so I'm
just gonna go with the wooden fences
mostly they kind of worked in a sense
now I only need conforming pieces for
the straight pipe so it should do two
just warming pieces for this and just
regular ones for other section though
here goes nothing only disadvantage only
disadvantage to tune this is the fact
that you that you do need to place the
poles I don't think I even want to do
that no plus it doesn't look as amazing
if I have two of the same fences on both
sides actually I think I'm gonna not do
it I might use one too so no I'm
thinking about it might as well try that
but
see oh it's just takes a bit of trial
and error so really I would suggest that
you never just go with offense right
away just to write multiple types of
fences and just in the end decide what
you're going to go for but really it
takes him trial and error to get the
perfect thing mmm this honestly isn't
the best thing there oh that bad but I'm
not gonna go with I'm not gonna go with
this no I should try ish in gyms for mmm
I should still get more offense that's
because I haven't nearly gotten all of
the fence that are out there but there's
just so many things out there and I
really need to pick some things up mmm
there should be informing people none of
these pieces actually conform though I
need to go in - no not in here no is it
logical would say that you've got leakin
but yeah they are in here okay good okay
so I'm just gonna mess with that I guess
um I do kind of want angel yeah
actually like that it's probably better
than having wood in both sides yeah I'm
just gonna go with this pretty cool and
we're only gonna do the other side as
well simply because I want to get that
out of the way so I can actually move to
the non-conforming parts of the fences
very nice now there's our damn it
I will have problems with that that's a
shame there's no way I can really get
around that
yeah there's no way I can do that I'm
just gonna have to figure something out
there are barely any fences that also
have conforming pieces for the herbs
watch out with that that's why I said in
the beginning that having curves that
kind of have a slope is generally not a
good idea because not many sets go with
it just like it's generally hard to get
diagonal buildings what was building
diagonally is a very good idea and it
looks great in many cases but you really
need to make sure that you have all the
sets that you need because there aren't
many sets that actual actually have
diagonal pieces and if they do there's
somewhat more limited than the normal
pieces though the same goes for
buildings as those four paths watch out
with that stuff but anyway this is all
the boring stuff basically the things
that you've already seen is just simple
though honestly that's also a good thing
because I don't really need to teach
anything new over here so I'm pretty
sure that anybody can really this envy
too quickly that but this is not going
to be not going to pose problems to many
people unless of course you've got all
the ones in that case yet
and like I've said before I always like
to do the curves first then the
diagonals and then the great point I
don't know why I just I just find that
in general it's just slightly harder to
get the right pieces for curves then
diagonals are somewhat more rare than
straight pieces at least with my way of
doing path work so I start off with the
more rare and harder to place elements
and then in the end I do all the easy
things
I don't know why it just works in a nice
way it also makes it easy to see at the
end where you have to play straight
pieces and stuff like that though
honestly the order doesn't really say
that much this is just what I prefer and
about these fences though this is just
something that I can only say about
these fences you can actually layer
these so you can actually place one here
and one half a tile over here if you
don't want to go through that hassle or
finding the half and yet in the menu it
doesn't really matter you get no
clipping the only disadvantage to it is
that you have a few more LEDs but that
really won't give you any more it's
pretty much yeah nothing though it
doesn't really matter only if you really
have like problems you should watch out
with actually layering things but in
this case especially with my laptop
since it's incredibly crappy but it can
still handle this thing easily though
doesn't really matter
and just a half one here now you can see
some slight differences but nothing like
this is generally something that you
won't really know to send pictures or
video so it doesn't really matter
honestly now of course if you do get a
greater gap like this it's already gonna
be more of a problem though honestly I
don't have any normal curve pieces for
that so I'll deal with that I can't do
anything about it but that's just
something to me to note it mmm yeah and
there we go just more curve stuff I'm
gonna then use the same fences over here
so Isis as well and as always I start
off with the curves and then start
filling out the straight thingies on I
don't think I really want to have sight
walk over here just gonna leave that out
now of course I might later on place an
attraction over here but I I'm not too
sure about that so as long as you're not
sure what you want to build something
just think that it doesn't exit it's
that's just what I always like to do
simply because if you don't build it
after all then it's it's been a good
thing that you've already kind of built
around it and if you do want to build
something it's not gonna be too hard
it's better to have something already
than to have to open all those sets
later on if you really decide that you
don't want to build something that
generally takes a lot of time and it's
pretty annoying sometimes it's funny how
people always are diagonal pieces in
many sets are actually offer tile wide
and they're not considered a half
diagonal they're considered a full
diagnose it's pretty funny
though not all sets dude is something
that I've noticed
though yeah I guess that's also good to
note that many sets you might think that
there is no foolin there you know peace
but really hot dog you know pieces are
often the only ones that they have so
you don't really need to look for any
full diagonal pieces because not all of
the sets have them it doesn't really
matter that much it doesn't take that
much only if you have a very light I
cannot well break the line I guess
alright it really saves time if you have
a four piece look good yeah I guess mmm
not I used wood over here so I'm just
gonna keep using the wood for that I'm
gonna have to close this and open
branches set again
I really like this sir right for right
answers mmm oh damn it this is something
I've talked about earlier yeah I've
known this is um this was being stupid
hmm right now there are multiple ways of
going around this though honestly what I
think I had an idea at the moment though
I can't be certain I'm pretty sure that
would be my asked self way of thinking
is adding a hedge or some other way of
agitation of over here so I think I'm
you know what go with that and where's
this fence doing over here get out of
there
what are you doing so what is that I am
pretty sure it is in station Jim's
running - but I'm not sure whether it's
over here which doesn't appear to be or
over at the object section which it
probably is because I'm looking for some
small hedges our own station - and there
we go beautiful hedges of these things
though am I going to do some tutorial
stuff on this yeah basically these
hedges have the same curves as mobis -
as mobis curves and shyguys curves and
there's something to notice is that
there are two different types of curves
that many sets because something resets
usually use you have the more common one
these shyguys curves that you've seen
before and everybody's very used to but
also you have mobis curves and they are
a little bit less common but Mobe uses
them and some other sets do as well they
have the lose curve l and r pieces and
stuff like that now this might be very
confusing at first but this is really
something to get used to and something
to notice it's something to note while
I'm using this set also you have the in
and out and that means nothing else than
the out piece is really on the edge of a
full tile and the in piece is somewhere
over here so it's more in the center I
can kind of demonstrate that yeah you
can see that the Epis
really is over there and the in piece is
within a tile Lee I'm different but
basically yeah
a name or any mix and kind of tells you
what it is and basically this has an
effect since a full hedge can either be
on this tile or on this tile so if
you're making a curve that goes right
over here you'll need basically an outer
piece with the left edge and an in piece
for the right hedge that's basically how
it works and this can take some getting
used to
and yeah that's pretty much it when it
comes to that now this is very handy
though because these loose curves can
really help you in some some certain
situations in which other things might
not and even though they have some weird
placements that have behaved in a
strange ways with the grid as you can
see you can really fit them snugly
around this little well or I call it
that I'm just gonna go for that and just
get the diagonal and straight pieces to
flesh this off
very not since I like smooth things
those things are really great one of the
best things to do in rollercoaster
country and if you really succeed at
this everybody's gonna love you right
well at least for that already I can't
promise that but really I would is to
hide the fact that it uses a grid as
much as possible so if you use many
curves and stuff like that and it's
really not obvious that rollercoaster
second three it has a grid in the way
that it does and then your ride
basically already knew only at that
point though definitely try to add as
many smooth things in curves and stuff
like that as you can and also diagonal
buildings can help with this but once
again diagonal buildings can be a pain
so yeah it's a double-edged sword in
that sense now I need to even I need to
figure out how this works because I'm I
don't really work with these sense much
no this should work honestly if you want
to get my opinion because now I'm
blabbering about this year anyway
I don't really like the curves in mobis
packs the mobis curves are just a bit
weird to work with and many of mobile
walls are therefore also not compatible
with shyguys planters and many other
fans sets and wall sets though that's a
bit unfortunate and annoying but in some
cases especially when you need those
offset pieces it really helps out when I
was building skyscrapers for Silver City
and even in that case mobis walls have
helped me out with some nice off piece
set off set pieces
well I missed up on that one though that
was really now I think I'm just gonna
actually finish my job so I can all
peace and probably shires peace mostly
is it some you need an outfit that we
don't because not like
only certainly not with this I like yeah
a little edge piece over here thank you
very much yeah that should work honestly
it's good enough it's not floating I'm
floating not too much though I mean I
don't really know I guess it's not good
module and when I add more gradually and
foliage and it's not gonna be two notes
also ruin I'm gonna go for that I don't
think I really want to add a house over
here yeah that house over there is
pretty much more than so it's time to
finish up other things now that we're
doing the boring things let's finish
this once and for all and do the very
well lacing stuff on the paths we need
more lamps and like that now of course
once again we've we've got so many lamp
sets in the Urraco second three
community it really just depends on what
your personal preference is hmm I mean I
don't actually know there's just many
sets that I like for the themes I like
these lamps though so I'm probably gonna
go with these all around the park also
they're not as widely used honestly i I
always prefer to use sets that are
somewhat more uncommon than others and
Bodines lights kit is pretty much one of
the most overused sets in the game
though sometimes I just avoid that set
for the sake of avoiding whatever you
any out and what everybody else use I
know it's it's a very hipster thing to
do but okay sorry I just do that
sometimes
it's also a bit all breaking in a sense
of well there's not really a well it's
not really a fourth Wharton
rollercoaster second three but it's kind
of sometimes it's it's immersion
breaking when you see certain there's
some scenery sets that you see everybody
using it just takes away from the over
creativity of the ride sometimes it just
takes away the idea of this of oh this
is an awesome thing that somebody made
and just kind of places an idea in my
head of oh he used that custom scenery
set hmm I recognized that I don't know I
just don't like that it's like how the
Wilhelm scream just kind of takes me out
of the movie is when I'm watching a
movie when I'm like really immersed in
the story and all that I suddenly you
hear the Wilhelm scream and you can't
help but laugh at it and then that's
pretty much good moment ruined yeah over
here I guess but I would want to use
some other over there do i I don't know
also somebody taught me to add planters
on these things and at first I was like
yeah that's a good idea because you have
the hanging baskets that you can use for
the lumps in gardening but you can't use
that for this specific type oh there's
no doing that you can though use that
for the other lights I'll just give that
a short demonstration of that for
example you have this light and it has
the steel beams on it and you can hang
it over there that's pretty cool that
the little beams on this one are way too
short to do that also I'm pretty sure
this lamp does it as well
yeah aslam does it as well so that's
pretty cool but once again it doesn't
work with
now I don't exactly want to use this
anymore I'm just gonna see if there's
anything else I feel like I should buy
something from this no do small to dark
but the efteling lights might know
they're a bit small to you'll like even
if I support it hmm I could work
honestly I could definitely work that I
might also try a different line it
definitely work
there's also lymph 24
which is slightly bigger yeah I'm gonna
go with the slightly bigger one now as
you can see of course they're floating
you bid but there's also something that
I kind of didn't want to talk about but
now now that I'm thinking about it it's
probably a good thing to mention
sometimes you you you the customer
series set that you're trying to use
basically it doesn't really have the
things that you want it to have it
doesn't exactly have specific pieces or
like these lime stitch is too small for
what I'm trying to make and I really
love it when people start mixing custom
scenery sets to make objects though
especially with lamps and stuff like
that you can mix certain sets in order
to make it something new I've seen
people use mobis steel jungle and then
adding lampposts to that and flowers
from other sets and stuff like that it's
just really awesome sometimes to use
custom scenery sets to create new
objects and though I'm not doing any of
that complicated stuff over here I'm
just trying to find something to animate
this lamp a bit higher with it's always
good to know that you can really mix up
sets really and it's really all really
awesome sometimes no this doesn't quite
work honestly though I need to find
something else maybe a post from one of
the whenever the path set honestly and
yeah this is one of the downsides to
doing that you really need to find
something you really need to mess around
with certain stuff until you've actually
found the thing that you really want and
this would have worked if only it were a
bit bigger no that's a shame though just
need to find something else maybe this
iron thing honestly it might still be
very small yeah that's very small that's
not gonna help out in that case maybe
the ornamental things it's something
that's slightly smaller than all of
these things hmm that doesn't quite work
out either quite the problem maybe no no
I'm thinking about it the station Jim
post then I don't really know posts in
here but maybe the more fencing those
have some I might be ooh it too big
though yeah this one I have a smaller
one or not if it does yes as actually I
was actually that might actually work oh
that's actually really nice actually
from like a small distance I wish so
except nicely the lamp on itself is just
a bit too more especially considering
that the other line said it slightly
bigger so I think this works out yeah
really nice now I did notice that I
forgot to add some fences over here I'm
going to quickly that or I forget about
this completely i scooping I still want
this set opened honestly that's funny
and I need to change the collet again
though I think this was it yeah
and there we go a couple fences and then
it's time to add some benches and and
call it a day I'm gonna do the fun stuff
later
so once it's and stuff like that I
really like doing winters and once again
I like doing flowers too I was awesome
Oh benches benches are hard to do
sometimes but I think I'm gonna do I'm
think I'm just gonna use the same bench
um throughout the pike many people use
photo Hughes benches and I often do that
as well but for this particular Pike I'm
just like I want to use gardening to
benches I'm just gonna go with that
let's see 1 ft e I love how it has the
gradual color change over here actually
goes from being too brown or depending
on what colors you have something else
but I'm going to use the brown on it so
I want to do it's also pretty cool
or maybe with some better some no not
red that's to your colorful I have a
better idea
bottom is gonna be like maybe and don't
change the oh that actually I actually
like that though it might even be better
if on integrate yeah that's cool okay
I'm just gonna go with that I love it
and I'm just gonna place a couple of
benches over here I forgot to place
lamps over here so I need to cut back to
actually I don't need to go back to
anything same set ice life is very nice
mmm pretty good
yeah and I'm just gonna leave this area
for now though I wouldn't like to add
some benches over here for people to
look at the roller code and I still want
to fix something about this ball because
even though I added those rocks and
those pillars it's a one big auntie
boring the wall though need some
washing-up and stuff on it and obviously
since people are gonna to look at the
roller coaster here as well and this is
kind of a Bulevar in a sense oh wow guys
ah whatever
I'll see you oh it's not there and now
of course you're not gonna place it that
one bill I'm to ruin your view this
should work fine this placement is a bit
odd oh well whatever and this I'm just
gonna well it's the path I guess it's
the most logical thing to do and maybe
this is too close to the author easily
put the benches over there because
there's no answer at being pretty safe
to do that only if there's a fence you
should watch out with that because
sometimes the bench will kind of go into
the fence a loop like that basically it
you don't have that problem with this
set with some sets the bench will
actually go over the line of the border
between two tiles so it's actually going
to go into the fence and that's just
generally something that you would
but for this it works fine though that's
all cool and over here now I prefer
placing the benches on sidewalks so I'm
just gonna leave areas on what bear but
I still want to place a call
benches are still awesome
not list of whether there's a sidewalk
or not and someday I gonna like in the
middle don't want to put benjin
and like I said don't want to put
benches what did I just do over here I
don't know about that honestly that's a
bit other than that though it's pretty
much fine now I just need to finish
those lights and of course I also need
to buy some litter bins and that's
something I'm going to talk about in a
minute but first I need to get this
these lamps and I'm just gonna place
them on the light walk
as I place them on the sidewalk over
there as well pretty funny sight walk
not only functions as a sort of a fancy
something next to the path but it also
function is something that on which you
place pretty much anything which you
want on the paths but you don't want to
be in the middle of the way no that's
pretty funny
I met these things gray so I messed up
on that one
goddammit gonna have to replace all of
them I also really need to finish this
little ciyon talk - really move on
though that I've really get everything
out the way that I need you yeah so I'm
gonna finish that border
real quick and then do some small little
bend stuff action and those small other
things that's pretty much it I just need
to finish might walk in a bee pain
anyway litter bins so station gyms
gardening also has amazing litter bins
though
thank you set for pretty much having
everything and making this very easy for
everyone no there's all of them Ashley
oh yeah
wooden one that's a wooden one and even
this one is wooden so that's really good
at least for this bike of course if you
have a more modern Pike this is not
really going to work but in this case
it's gonna work out fine so I'm just
gonna go or either one of these things
it's not really too great I like this
one a lot so I'm gonna go with this one
really this just depends on whatever it
have been you like
I can see that I already play someone
went over there mmm that's strange
and now something that I wanted to say
about this is that sometimes I see
people spamming little little bins
everywhere all around the park and
really you don't need that many litter
bins so it looks a bit weird if you have
little bin little bins everywhere and
it's pretty much a rush fast so I would
I would say try to avoid that really
sometimes people feel like inclined if
their paths are somewhat empty and they
have like a fear of emptiness they just
want to fill it with stuff that's
generally what I have as well but watch
out with that stuff with little bins
because it is too much very quickly this
I already be too much yes might get me
this sidewalk need some
this one's
I should do I should definitely do oh
wait this one now also a common thing to
do is kind of place them next to benches
people are going to sit on them and eat
and throw this throw that [ __ ] away
basically unless you put little pins
next to the benches make sure that
people don't make a mess of everything
yeah okay that works now there's little
sidewalk burger if the worse for lost
why did I do that you don't diagonal to
straight piece action over here yeah
that's kind of that's kind of glitching
us where you Oh God
I'll screw you I don't know how to fix
that actually there's no fix for that
other than using conforming sets but I
don't have conforming sets or pieces for
this and I know what to change all of
that so I'm gonna just procrastinate
that or just leave it out altogether
because obviously I don't want to do
with all the time
you
you
this works
and need to flip it for the other side
and get that other not that hard
it's really not something that you
really it's just something that you need
to put time in it's just one of those
things in which you don't need any
talent you don't need any knowledge of
how to do things you just need to invest
time it's not that it's not the greatest
thing once there's something that you
have to do
Arthur work
now of course path works can be
beautiful amazing and you can put lots
of time in into path works I've done
that as well
but that that kind of and he goes for
when your path works is actually when
your path work is actually the main
focus or at least you're making like a
central boulevard or something like that
but in many of these cases I'm just
gonna fill these with quarters it
honestly doesn't really matter you can
bill half the aisles with quarters it
saves police to fill them with halves
and it saves time if you do it in an
efficient way
but it said this the police that it
saves you it's pretty much nothing once
again especially with paths things us
don't have any police these things are
not gonna like him when you compare you
can I don't know how many but some
custom scenery pieces literally have
thousands of faces and a path I covered
only has either two faces or six faces
so you can place hundreds and hundreds
of path pieces just to cover from one
tree or something like that oh it really
doesn't matter too much okay so that
looks pretty good especially this area I
love it alright basically that's it for
this episode and in the next episode I
think I'm going to do some planter stuff
and maybe some other fun stuff maybe
some more foliage so cool things so
thank you for watching guys hope you've
learned something and see you on the
next one